well to a mouthful of live moths an army
of cats and a crazy bad middle of fan
have in common Hocus Pocus might not be
the cold classic it is today without
them
although today he's one of the top
actors in Hollywood Leonardo DiCaprio
was young and improvent in the early
1990s his first official movie credit
came via critic 3 in 1991 and he starred
alongside Robert De Niro in his next
feature film
1993's This Boy's Life according to him
the actor then had to make a difficult
Choice as to which film he wanted to
appear in next in a 2014 interview with
variety DiCaprio recalled being offered
more money than he ever dreamed of to
star in Hocus Pocus instead of accepting
however he opted to hold out for a role
in What's Eating Gilbert Grape a movie
he hadn't even auditioned for yet the
Oscar winner admitted I don't know where
the hell I got the Nerf but if there's
one thing I'm very proud of it's being a
young man who was sticking to my guns
the capriott auditioned for the part of
Max Denison which eventually went to
Dallas actor on recurs well cats gave a
fine performance as a film's leading man
you have to wonder just how different
Hocus Pocus would have looked with a
future a-lister like DiCaprio in the
role foreign
[Applause]
eagle-eyed fans on Reddit have noticed
that in the Halloween party scene of
Hocus Pocus there's someone in the
background wearing what appears to be an
outfit from 1982's Tron as it turns out
so that Man's costume is more authentic
than you might realize when speaking to
glamor Mary votes the costume designer
for Hocus Pocus admits it that she
spends almost all the Wardrobe budget
creating the iconic looks of the
Sanderson sisters and the zombified
Billy butcherson this made for a
particularly sticky situation when a
script called for the denizens to attend
a crowded Halloween party toward the end
of the film the vote had completely run
out of money so what did she do well she
took advantage of the fact that she was
working on a Disney movie raiding the
Walt Disney costume department and
selecting outfits from a slew of old
Disney movies the emmy-nominated costume
designer record I think that if you paid
five thousand dollars you could have
whatever you want so I went through
there and took everything that looked
like a costume no wonder so many of
those Halloween outfits look so
impressively genuine
there's a scene in Hocus Pocus when the
zombified Billy butcherson finally
catches up to Max and the gang but then
in a plot twist size with the children
against his ex-lovers you might recall
that during this scene Billy cuts open
his own mouth and several moths fly out
being that this was the 90s the stunt
was performed without the assistance of
CGI but you have to imagine that Doug
Jones a veteran physical Maestro who
brought butcherson to life wishes there
was in an interview with Bloody
Disgusting Tony Gardner the makeup
effects Master behind Hocus Pocus shared
some photos and facts about the film's
behind the scenes happenings including
that Jones actually had real master in
his mouth during that scene Gardner
explained that his team attached the
latex pocket between the actor's upper
and lower Dentures completely blocking
his throat and then came the moths an
animal Wrangler would Place several moss
in the bucket with tweezers under the
supervision of a representative from the
Humane Society Jones himself vividly
recalls The Experience telling E news
that he could feel the Moss fluttering
around and inside his mouth making
matters worse a light burst on sets
while filming the first attempt so Jones
had to redo the entire process in
retrospect Jones probably deserves an
Academy Award for enjoying the mosque
not once but twice there's a joke Jimmy
Kimmel said about a strict policy that
he has I will not and do not publicize
unsubstantiated rumors about anyone
unless they're very funny this must have
been the mindset that Doug Jones had
when he publicly shared a pretty wild
rumor about his legendary co-star Bette
Midler telling E news I heard rumor that
she had written into a contract that
there had to be an isolated shot of her
feet walking somewhere in the film while
Anonymous rumors are obviously not a
solid source of information there are
actually two very suspicious shots of
middler's feet to join the Halloween
party scene that certainly lent fuel to
the fire one when she enters the room
and another when she's walking across
the stage while it could simply be a
coincidence Jones isn't buying why would
they even bother to put that clip in
there I think it was contractual
sometimes it takes a good movie several
years to become fully appreciated
there's a plethora of solid films that
bombed at the box office because they
were arguably ahead of their time
including cult classics like Labyrinth
Heathers and of course Blade Runner
which famously only took home 26 million
dollars on a reported budget of 28
million dollars but is now recognized as
one of the best sci-fi flicks of all
time poker's Focus achieved a similar
type of delayed appreciation when
speaking to Forbes in 2020 director
Kenny Ortega opened up about how poorly
the film did at the box office only
grossing 39.5 million dollars honestly
at that point I thought it was all over
for me however history had other plans
for the director and his little film but
could Hocus Pocus slowly but surely
landed with its intended audience
evolving into something truly special
looking back Ortega is grateful for the
example the movie set in his life what
I've learned is don't give up I believed
in Hocus Pocus and even though it wasn't
found by audiences immediately the
Generations have believed in him
they say don't meet your Heroes but
Kathy and Jimmy would beg to differ
before she landed the role of Mary
Sanderson the Jimmy was already familiar
with her on-screen sister Bette Midler
however the two had never actually met
during a 2019 interview with Metro
Weekly the Veep actress explained that
she had been a quote crazy sicko friend
fan of biddlers growing up so getting
Cass to play her sister in hoka's Pocus
was a dream come true when I was growing
up my the idol of my life was Bette
Midler and I used to break into
backstages of where she was performing
in addition to sneaking backstage at her
shows that Jimmy also admitted to one
audacious occasion in which she posed as
a worker for a singing telegram company
and sang Midler a song while wearing a
bunny suit when asked whether she ever
told Midler that she was a bunny suit
singer from her past but Jimmy says she
did come clean but it probably took
Midler a while to come to terms with her
I think it was just a very slow sort of
like oh God I'm making a movie with a
crazy person into very good castmates
and Friends while hocus focus is
obviously a fictional Tale the roots of
Witchcraft in early America are anything
but the Salem Witch Trials of 1692 are
some of the most fascinating events in
American history albeit a Grizzly
example of how intense paranoia can lead
to mass chaos over the course of seven
months over 200 people in the Puritan
town of Salem Massachusetts were accused
of Witchcraft ultimately resulting in 20
innocent people being murdered one such
person accused of Witchcraft was named
Esther Dutch Elwell who as fate would
have it is actually the 10th great
grandma to actress Sarah Jessica Parker
the ditzy witch Sarah Sanderson and
Hocus Pocus the Sex and the City Star
learned of their stunning relation in
2010 while appearing on the American
version of the British TV series who do
you think you are fortunately for Elwell
the trial court for witchcraft was
dissolved a few weeks before her hearing
so she was freed and able to live a full
life still the fact that one of her
distant relatives would eventually play
a witch from roughly that same time
period as a rather fortuitous
coincidence
although Hocus Pocus is clearly a movie
intended for the Halloween season it
actually hit theaters in July this means
that filming for the movie actually took
place around Christmas time which made
things a little tricky while summer
focused Focus was filmed at studios in
California some of the production did
actually take place in Salem
Massachusetts for authenticity
unfortunately when the crew traveled to
Salem people were starting to put up
their Christmas ornaments while holiday
cheer is great this was for the wrong
holiday this action had to be taken so
the filmmakers got out their checkbooks
and began approaching the locals add
dirt Tobias jelinek told e-news they
were having to pay them out block by
block to take down all their decorations
so we could get all the Halloween stuff
one of the scenes shot in La is the one
in which Max Dany and Alison celebrates
having just bested The Witches by
dancing around in a park outside the
school although there's nothing
particularly special about this short
scene internet sleuths have discovered
an unexpected cameo in the background as
it turns out this seemed was filmed at
the Old Warner Brothers Ranch in Burbank
the exact same location where the iconic
intro for friends were shot you can
clearly see the fountain that Joey
Rachel and the Gang play around then
behind Dany as she prances in the park
that's entertaining as Hocus Pocus is
the Journey of the screenplay behind the
movie is arguably even more interesting
at the 2018 Midsummer scream some of the
casts and crew members from Disney's fan
favorite Halloween flick reunited for
the 25th anniversary of the film's
release one of the members on the panel
was David kirschner a man credited with
creating the story kirschner explained
that it started as a bedtime story he
would tell to his daughters he
eventually wrote this as a short story
and it got published in Muppet magazine
then in 1986 the story was transformed
into a screenplay where it would sit in
limbo for eight years then kirschner
finally did sell the story to Disney he
reportedly brought in loads of Halloween
decorations including a giant bag chunk
full of candy corn so that the
executives smelled their childhood while
he gave his pitch
[ __ ] Banks a young boy from the late
1600s was cursed by winner Fred
Sanderson to live forever in the form of
a black cat
Bings is one of the high points of the
movie periodically cracking jokes at
Max's expense while watching over Dany
as though she was his own sister take
good care of Danny Max
you'll never know how precious she is
according to Humane Hollywood there were
several different cats that played Banks
throughout the movie and the handlers
chose which cat would appear in which
scene based on their skills and
personalities American Humane was
present throughout production ensuring
that no animals were harmed during
filming it's truly impressive what the
crew was able to accomplish with animal
actors
foreign
[Music]